oh this is quite nice I guess I nice
jank a little what's that uh what's
going on here like I see some trees I
see some ID some shadow I say what's
going on though okay I'm all right I'm
stuck here again Panik is coming and
anxiety all right um Oh what is that a
little peckerhead look at that if I can
wake him out this is nice this is nice
it guys up out here Here I am ah
everything is fine Jim was a Janklow too
much last night back in the woods you
know the usual [ __ ] I which ways home
shud i can t remember what party oh that
last night [ __ ] up [ __ ] how I still my
condoms I got god i still have no big
mistakes oh wait [ __ ] what I didn't use
a condom last night not great but this
is just great ok if I could you know
there a lot up yeah I could jump ok it's
right better get home or my wife finds
out as god oh god get ok and I thought
that you could die all right it's gonna
just just gonna be in there very nice
very nice now you see that so mirrors
that [ __ ] right there get out here ok
and
right click no space now
and skate by oh okay [ __ ] settings
here the controls are action is control
how the [ __ ] with highs what's now that
okay
thank God good God okay
and up
yeah you don't know how many times I
have to do this to get out of the house
sunday is the lot is all the way over
the door and I just had to [ __ ] guys
swing
he's a guy is it it's me just fine about
to [ __ ] do this wrist he's good the
[ __ ] hot that baby's nose piercing
white eyes okay I guess I'll just cover
here sure hope i don't mean any sea
monsters you know this is nice
everything is okay you know just just
chill you know Jess I had to count how
many times I woke up on a boat get any
count that high you know it's like
[ __ ] pie you know okay
[ __ ] die [ __ ] you're right great great
great how do i okay
pressing ctrl nothing's happening and I
could get a good good game is this do
this ah I say I say you can do this i'm
not i'm not to tell me nuh uh oh just
[ __ ] kill myself mother [ __ ]
embarrassing ok look closer little
closer for hammy that's an all named him
he may I want him oh oh oh ok oh I'm
done a little spider monkey ain't I yeah
yeah it's ok it's ok all right I don't
we get some rabid deer you know you're
out of their hair yeah Sarah Sarah how
but what is that oh I say no say no ok
jumper Oh tried to jump I guess I jumped
a little too late ok ok
i press control yeah jump over this guy
okay okay all right taught me that
[ __ ] up my leg this early in the
morning what is that
yeah Sarah
huh
hey
second disgusting it's all right there
oh ok uh scared of getting very dark
very fast when I say dark i don't mean
the racist art ok i don't really racist
dark I mean like I guess like contrast
art Oh God good good saying here yep yep
yep
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
nice [ __ ]
alright
I've got good good and I'm just a happy
little boy and I like show or like
there's underage drinking and drugs but
like and I was a must but I'm just a
little guy yeah I heard oh [ __ ] I hit
don't worry oh you know like if I had a
dollar for everything I woke up with a
ball coming at me I'd have liked a
dollars so how do you like this footage
guys unedited uncut okay I've got like a
for skin for skin that is way too long
you know okay gone through here god
they're here I cat okay
second sucks oh okay found out I can't
swim at all that's fine
hmm
I man
they're yay
ah okay very interesting how things are
playing out
um I got here this little patch no say
I'd say here you go oh god oh god oh god
[ __ ] legs are so weak are they gonna
work it out
yeah yep yep okay he goes it Bethany a
guy is that it out life isn't it up push
oh good god that's over here nothing too
good
Jesus am i a [ __ ] spider monkey okay
okay
Oh chases history [ __ ] scary
huh ah my god this guy just got a gun
and God like you know like a little i
have a jazzer body can't kind of dark
out here oh I don't know up there ok so
he get that down not a lot of danger
shut up ok ma'am
[ __ ]
oh did not know about that oh [ __ ] go
okay all right that happened ok let's
say let's see i bet i have to like make
it missing grab it hey check it was a
good shot ok [ __ ] that
and I did this
okay I got make it raised buck
he says
oh ok that work that worked I guess I
way from just [ __ ] hit the ground and
knock your [ __ ] off ok he's a guys at oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] scared it ok got a little boy
Kel couch is again kel kel god
I've got gets hurt and more
Oh mommy that's [ __ ] i think we're
[ __ ] huge yeah I got I got I got yep
no [ __ ] okay good i slide yeah he's
getting [ __ ] dark that's all I gotta
say ooh smooth move Ferguson smooth move
Ferguson all right yep it is getting
[ __ ] dark good thing my eyes I met
glow yeah I like in a web take sticky
can't jump
great great i can't get out of here oh
great great great great how do I get out
of here right I guess I'm going with him
now this is my new life I accept that ok
alright that's fine I like this it's
comfy
alright I guess that's fine it's okay
all right wake up this [ __ ] here I got
this [ __ ] hello ma'am how lucky for me
now you get a wiggle everywhere all
right I'm like a [ __ ] like cement egg
thing wow I don't flies it is just
[ __ ] leg okay um change of plans nope
[ __ ] embarrassing
hey her at the time to Johnson oh ok I
got I got oh sneaky don't deem that the
morning and I'm no good evening I'm
hindi I'm just a little hopper right
thing ok ok um excuse me sir excuse me
harden is [ __ ] ok hmm i nee I'm just a
lot of web China get home after a bender
oh oh oh oh
chef
I'm [ __ ] oh [ __ ] mommy wants her
medicine oh no leave me wait me before
she gets me yeah yeah yeahs [ __ ] up
things in sk that's all i gotta say a
lot of [ __ ] up pink in this game oh oh
ok wasn't that wasn't part of the plan
ok oh oh okay all right there are times
a charm all right um you know just doing
normal web things my feet are so cute
looking like I'm making a onesie all
right where's mama spider where I sure
there's yes right on time you know it's
funny when there's food then you show up
but when there's naughty and it's hard
work to do you know what to be found
just tell ya that works out but side ok
any kind of scary
oh oh oh oh [ __ ] that rise and shine
little one rise and shine I got some
[ __ ] on her head great way to get that
off jaysus like jizz my Sally ok
yeah [ __ ] is getting dark where have I
[ __ ] god I mean sometimes I wake up
in a pharmacy but this is all different
now I thought we can happen a pharmacy
was bad but Jesus
oh oh oh oh oh
ah you know should i just spent the
night
that was a very dangerous plan okay
oh [ __ ] okay okay you know you get there
a lot of [ __ ] at me but I hangover is
probably gonna prepare me for the worst
ok not expect that I know I'm planning
for that now oh [ __ ] is that music Jess
you're hunting along don't like me
[ __ ] oh I took off like a trap it's good
good Oh
[ __ ] Oh run [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] I'm
gonna hook you up that [ __ ] is trying
to kill me are they [ __ ] was that noise
[ __ ] I died by a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ok
a little more to beat that oh [ __ ] i
think was on fire the [ __ ]
this dude is out
[ __ ] he's got brethren [ __ ] you and yeah
hey times I woke up on the beach without
a beach permit Jesus [ __ ]
our little legs I sure got a dorrance
know are you [ __ ] up sky alive or
dead tell me see your little trap think
I don't see that don't see that oh
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] okay let's see if
I can jump out of the way nope not a
possibility
hey it's getting [ __ ] hard okay okay
okay oh [ __ ] no
Jesus yeah the things I do to just try
and get by in the world [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
are you [ __ ] yeah throw more on me see
what I can do what don't [ __ ] [ __ ] I
got myself yeah oh ok I guess now I turn
to die yet
Oh what the [ __ ] I didn't ever get
[ __ ] do that
okay you say whatever go left nothing is
there a thing I can down here okay God
Jesus and out that God all right Ron
bechara
so I gotta wait for this [ __ ]
come on how that says it uh-huh faster
like a skinny I am
[ __ ] this guy's kind of [ __ ] fast
[ __ ] runnin I'm runnin no no no no cat
yeah as a hat you know I think it worked
out best for everybody think everyone
involved is happy how can I end it and
it's gonna [ __ ] fall no where's that
this guy does not get a break you know
come on man let's it lets the Silas's
befriend you know let's get home pretty
good forest yeah it just goes to show
that I'm better oriented I'm job because
if I got this far when I was drunk and
I'm [ __ ] good okay um yeah right now
[ __ ] was that
Oh
come on got my little one come on
now i get there for daddy
Jesus I gotta do jump on your [ __ ]
head
yeah let's go let's go
no [ __ ] disgusting that is probably
one of the grossest things I have ever
seen
ok
you is it like still alive looking at me
this is [ __ ] sick [ __ ] some morbid
reality check to the eyes see the bump
we park we're gonna touch it Oh what
something disgusting I'm sorry sorry for
your loss yeah I can't anything I don't
say that
[ __ ]
it's not here yeah I got to get that
crook the slide down there that's it i
think that's what I think all right [ __ ]
face
good good good you know I'd like how
things work out slide he goes that he
goes okay a lot of work for this guy a
lot of work
the front
ladies white thanks eel side Marva that
is [ __ ] and us you did make them like
zombies you
is some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I'm going into uncharted territories
[ __ ] is gonna be [ __ ] up I know it not
all right Jill trap this time
very funny guys very funny I'm ready to
get your eyeing into there uh yes good
good good all right buddy you're coming
with me proficient in dragon bodies
that's all I gotta say
oh yes yes yes I see he's not there now
huh huh yeah dad got hmm to [ __ ] an egg
honey what is that oh it's a guy in
distance where the wake up no it's just
another trap [ __ ] hey I was just
gonna jump over that little thing huh
years ago here's again
my lord this [ __ ] did I let's grab its
body or something combat count with me
same crap
ok pika [ __ ] murder it's okay Jesus
mmm okay all right I gotta think I get
the rules now oh ok so that one it's a
pressure plate you guys have to miss
that one yeah okay now okay now what
happens here hmm getting very dark I'm
sure I gotta do that
ok
this guy's gonna make it good good good
good you know okay not a problem solved
with violence
savage oh that's a day I I can savages
what else is this game gonna throw at me
you know get in here how it works
chef I can move this on good night honey
at a time like I says
well set how the [ __ ] tight you this
are you serious bro yeah it's up in the
air something behind this
hmm
nothing in there
down here
oh ok just a little death
okay okay here's the plan
genius
you
down here okay let's jump over here
okay a lot more time I thought it's okay
it's okay
cuz they don't need for it and
you
okay way this jump down here
last tell do that what does not [ __ ]
alright
right doc what is the purpose of this
that's not I'm trying to figure out
I can idea like an idea here's the plan
I just grab this rope at the bottom
it's the work
[ __ ] answer that for ok I got it I got
ya they gave you a little smoother with
all this smoother smooth as a baby's
bottom you know a newborn not a sexual I
just like a marble way yeah everything a
marble statue
okay ready right shut our [ __ ] oh oh
I got it I got it
what is that come on come on yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah genius genius
genius yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but is that some sense baby yeah
what is that Adam [ __ ] now not gonna
ask us that [ __ ] in mostly probably
dangerous yeah for that oh god oh ok ok
this is going well I guess ok so I can't
control what direction I'm going but I
can control the speed
okay so no matter what okay let's do
this let's do this ya know must resist
resist okay I good idea i think have to
push that box and then jump up to them
here we go it's actually [ __ ] I know
that go that way I know get get get okay
here's the plan ready that's just [ __ ]
that's just [ __ ] okay so turn around put
sound like light good good okay I did it
again get the [ __ ] out of here maybe he
doesn't like light and that's what makes
it turn around
oh yeah
ok
what is that a toad hello Todd well I go
to the left now [ __ ] going on what is
that it's like an obstacle course
okay okay that I just died
this may be an interesting puzzle
interesting puzzle and i looked old I
could scare him or something into the
whole thing Oh in clouds things they're
cool Keller's won't help
and I get up there now any more chains
yeah huzzah
yeah I la frog a [ __ ] shout at you what
gets you [ __ ] I got you [ __ ] let's go
not shine that's right get in there
it's a little harder runner
oh I get that connect that
hang on
this son
like this extent
huh [ __ ] still not close enough well
like that
why is he huh
huh
Oh
yes about
this is god
doreen I really [ __ ] up with that
machine saw like I said lobby right
my sweater pendant
oh ok well
but [ __ ] am I going in here for not make
any sense
and I'm entering the steam rooms
farther
mmm ok just find out what's gonna happen
thank you
go go go go go go go go go go go go
spidermonkey go yes baby now bring me
too daddy
and they do not make this thingy so as
our [ __ ] spikes on its own
I got a store
chef
it's God's go
it's nothing
this is getting really crazy pretty
quickly
all I gotta say
what the [ __ ]
oh I can see just a push
[ __ ] are you [ __ ]
head over there
Snyder
exactly sure to happen now but we'll say
I like it
Athene late [ __ ] days
hmm
right it's like we're just gonna pick it
out
[ __ ] is getting difficult as all I gotta
say
did I mess up
hmm
oh oh can I climb this now
what happens if I go turn this and then
turn the other stuff
[ __ ]
hmm okay
chef Kenny their package
yeah [ __ ]
okay i'm working on oh come on get this
water out here
there we go okay they did it
I phase worms where's the [ __ ] spider
dude I hate this [ __ ] I just avoid him
ok that was ground that bus a zest yeah
the guys have to read as long as I can
Jesus ok last can I do over here get
there hey maybe like slow myself down
is that water can aim it the lightest
thing that makes me turn around
that day
no no no no no no no no no gotta figure
something out here if I [ __ ] just
shocking maybe have to try and get it
over in like one leap just gonna make me
kill myself that's fine everything's
fine oh so close a long time maybe have
to drain the water now or something
can't think this guy
all right well I guess we're just gonna
end it there I'll try to figure out what
the [ __ ] going on here but you know
the time and we're just gonna find out
more
until next time that is